So we've talked about the main events
in Nmr spectroscopy for determining
structure that is about,
um,
about the chemical shift and about
spin spin splitting that that, uh,
allows you to tell how many
nearby nuclei there are a,
today we're going to talk about,
uh,
some complications that make the
spectrum more complicated, uh,
and perhaps more informative, uh,
in terms of high order effects,
higher order effects in spins,
been splitting and then
about using Nmr to study,
not structure but to study rates.
And we'll do some [inaudible]
labeling stuff there. So spin,
spin splitting with other nuclei besides,
uh,
besides protons next door.
And we actually saw some of this last
time with deuterium splitting with, uh,
[inaudible] splitting.
For example,
if there's a signal like this and
you blow it way up by 30 times,
then you can see that what gives
these things that are so far apart,
126 hertz.
Do you remember this last one?
What are the size of splittings you
normally see for protons that are on
adjacent carbons there?
The order of seven hertz right here,
we got 126.
What's the big thing that's going on?
What makes a coupling so big?
Okay,
it's c 13 h in fact,
uh,
so 99% of the sample,
if you haven't specifically put,
see thirteens in there are see 12 but
about 1% or see 13 so you'll see that.
Now here's a paper from from 1959 which
first noted something interesting about
these see 13 h coupling constants that
they relate to the amount of s character
in the carbon atomic orbital
that's involved in the bonds.
Remember we said that the,
that the information has
to be communicated through
the electrons because the
action of of a magnets through space,
if you average overall angles of
rotation in a liquid goes to zero, right?
So you communicate through the bonds.
The nice thing about that is so strong
for JC 13 age is the thisi 13 has just
one bond to get to the age.
So it's a very short path to communicate.
Okay?
Now,
but you remember also that to do that
so that it doesn't average out as you
tumble the s you have to have
the electrons in an s orbital.
So the hydrogen uses it's s orbital,
that's all it's got essentially.
But carbon can use SRP. So the
hybridisation, as they say here,
relates to the coupling
constant, uh, because they, the,
to communicate that electron must
be on the [inaudible] nucleus.
So this is a table from that paper.
It gives the coupling constant
in units of per second,
those were then changed to be
called Hertz nowadays. Okay.
So here are a bunch of different,
and they're JC 13 h coupling constants.
If we make a histogram of them,
you see that there's a group between 100
2,141 between 150 and 170 and another
group down around two 50. So there,
there are different groups evolved here.
There are three different populations.
We could draw the lines between them.
And then if we look to see what the
carbons are that bear these hydrogens that
show that splitting, uh, we could look
first at the very big ones down there.
And what's special about those carbons
that are splitting the hydrogens right
there? Triple bonded. So sp hybridization,
50% s in the bond to hydrogen,
right? The ones here,
the green ones, right, are
in aromatic systems, right?
So they have sp squared hybridization
except for cyclo propane.
Why would it have such a, such
a high coupling? Constant?
Why would it have a lot of s
character in the bond to hydrogen?
The carbon that's in a cycle of propane,
right?
Because it's bonds normally
or tetrahedral SPQ cubed.
But when you try to make a smaller angle,
right?
It's more p character in the, in the, uh,
in the bonds to the other carbons,
therefore more s character
coming out to the hydrogens.
So we can actually see that
hybridization change in the Nmr.
And then these other are normal, a methyl
groups, SB cubed, hybridized carbons.
So here in,
uh,
in Nmr we have direct evidence for this
hybridization stuff we talked about last
semester. Okay, so it's
SPSP squared s cubed.
Now here's a subtle point,
uh,
perhaps we shouldn't be spending
time on it, but it's so interesting.
And I suspect the curious among you
may have wondered about this because we
talked about a coupling goes
through the bonds, right?
So from h to see,
to see to age,
how about h to c to h?
That's a shorter path,
right? So methane, if you're
looking at one hydrogen,
how many other hydrogens, which you
think it would be coupled to three,
right? And they could be
in one, three, three, one.
So you should see a quartet for a
proton of ch four. But you don't,
you just see a single sharp peak.
So where did the splitting go?
And this is related to what we talked
about last time, where a book said that,
that there is the splitting constant,
a zero. And I said, that's not true.
The splitting constant is high,
might be 10, but it's not observable.
So why is it, why doesn't, why
don't you see quartets for ch four?
Okay, so here's a one of these spectrum.
Actually, if you, if you go up here, uh,
and you can click on that and
get taken to the website of a,
of chem two 20 where they have problems.
I'll work one problem later
in the class if we have time.
But there are others you
can practice on there.
So this is a compound and I'll tell
you it's answer. It's cinnamic acid.
It's related to the Aldehyde
related to this acid cinema.
Aldehyde is the smell of cinnamon day.
So what do we expect when
we look at the Proton spot?
This is the proton spectrum of it.
What do we expect? Well, notice that,
that we can draw a resonance structures,
which will put positive charge
on the carbon with that hydrogen.
So remove electron density from that
hydrogen or from that one or that one or
that one.
So those all should be shifted down field
relative to where they would otherwise
be relative to the ones that
aren't blue. Right? So, uh,
when we,
when we look at the compound,
then we see these really
complicated peaks in here.
We throw up our hands
trying to understand that.
And then we see here two
doublets really nice, Sharp,
clean things. So what do you think
the two doublets are out here?
Let's ignore that bit for the time
being and talk about these two doublets.
What do you, what's protons do you think
those come from? Which one is this?
Okay. And let me start going around the
compound. The O H is way down further.
We're not showing that. Okay, so I'll
go down. I come to his, this one.
What do you think that is
right now?
That's the one up here. This is where
a double bonds normally come, right?
Then you come here and that one
is a carbon on a hydrogen audit.
Double bonded carbon.
But it's down here because it's,
it's lost electron density,
right?
Where we drew resonance structure
where the blue ones were more positive.
And then here we have hydrogens that are
on the benzene ring shifted down this
way because of the ring shift,
the aromatic ring current that
we talked about last time, right?
And now there's a group of three
and a group of two. These are,
these are positive and are shifted down.
That's the group of to the group of three
here is these two plus this one which
would shift to be shifted down because
it's positive but up because it's far
from this sp squared carbon. Let's not
worry about why that is, but at any rate,
that's the benzene ones, but that's not
what we're going to talk about here.
What we're going to talk about is the
clean signals here and here. Okay?
Now this is measured with a
magnetic field of 7.05 Tesla.
That means it's a 300
megahertz spectrometer,
so instead of using parts
per million down here,
we could change to hertz if we wanted
to change to a frequency scale and in
terms of frequency,
if we call zero the middle,
then that's a lower frequency at the top,
higher frequency to the bottom. Okay?
Now it turns out that the ratio
of the chemical shift difference,
Delta measured in Hertz,
not in parts per million.
We want to be comparing apples
with apples here hurts with hertz,
so the chemical shift from here to
here is much bigger than the coupling
constant Jay,
right?
It's 24.4 times as large and
that's the pattern we see.
Now suppose we used a smaller
magnetic field, right?
What's going to happen?
The chemical shift in parts per
million will stay the same, right?
But it'll be the same fraction
of a smaller frequency.
If we use a smaller field,
the precession frequency gets smaller.
So if we measure in Hertz as we're doing
here, they'll come closer together.
But Jay will stay the same
because it doesn't depend on
the field, right? The Mag,
the magnets are not dependent on the
field right there. Coupling. Okay,
so what will happen? These two
doublets will move together, right?
So 2.89 it turns out the
ratio is 10 or 0.86 a Tesla.
It would be three notice incidentally
that this would be a much cheaper
spectrometer because it would,
it would have only attempt as big.
The magnetic field is the other one,
right?
But also those other peaks
are going to be in the middle.
Everything's going to be getting on top
of one another and I'm just showing you
what would happen to this double doublet.
Okay.
There is a 0.29 and finally,
if we're a hundred times smaller at 0.2
for the ratio of chemical shift to Jay
measured in the same units and hurts,
you get the purple pattern.
Now notice that the j is always the same,
the splitting between the two peaks, but
what do you notice between the doublet?
What's curious about this?
I mean,
I'm sure you all see
some of the peaks are disappearing and
others are getting stronger as they come
together,
right?
The outer peaks are getting very weak
and in the limit where the chemical shift
was zero,
right?
The difference as in methane,
then the outer peaks disappear
altogether and you just see one peak.
Okay?
Now notice that that part in the original
spectrum was a mess because all those
hydrogens of the of the benzene ring
have similar chemical shifts and they're
all coupled with one another.
So it's more of this same thing at
all on top of one another and very
complicated.
So we'll forget that.
Let's think about what causes this change.
This is so called higher order effect,
not the simple thing that
you have a chemical shift,
count the neighbors and get
one to two to one, one, three,
three, one, one, four, six,
four, one kind of thing. Okay?
So here we are plotting the energy in a
big applied field of different nuclear
spin states. And we're talking
about just two nuclei, okay?
So they could both be with the field that
would be low in energy or one with and
the other against or against them,
the other width.
And then they could both be
against the applied field.
So you'd have these different energies,
right? And that's the 100 megahertz. This,
that's the energy that it would take
to get from here to here, right? By,
uh, flipping the red spin would
be a hundred megahertz, right?
But now, so, but all of
these look the same, right?
Whether you do a red line and flip the
Red Arrow or do a blue line and flipped
the Blue Arrow there.
All the hundred megahertz or whatever
frequency or 300 megahertz in that
spectrum we were looking at before.
Okay.
So we're going to see just a
single peak at at first glance,
but if we hold men and magnify things
so we can see small differences.
So in large this center
portion by a factor of 10 to
the fifth so we can see the
difference.
It's just a part per million in the
difference between the environment of the
blue and the environment of the
Red Proton. Then as we expand that,
we see that they're not quite the same.
It's harder to flip the blue proton
than it is to flip the Red Proton.
The Blue Proton is in a higher field
because of the chemical shift difference
and if we call that difference Delta
over to now you'll notice that that made
the red line's shorter by Delta over to
and the blue lines longer by Delta over
to doing that.
Okay,
so now we're going to see a chemical shift
of Delta one is smaller by Delta over
to the other,
larger by Delta over to the differences
Delta that Kevin uncle shift. Okay.
So that's the chemical shift.
And now suppose the spins interact
not only with the big blue field,
but also with each other.
And just suppose that there are coupling
through these electrons is such that
they prefer to be anti parallel.
You could have the opposite
sign of the coupling constantly.
They could prefer to be parallel,
but let's suppose they
prefer to be anti parallel.
So the ones where they're anti
parallel will go down in Nrg,
the ones where their power parallel,
we'll go up in energy. Okay,
so let's do that.
Okay.
And now what happened to the,
to the red and blue peaks?
Notice that this red peak got this
red transition, went to lower energy,
but this one went to higher energy,
right?
And this blue one went to lower energy,
but this blue one went to higher energy.
Everybody see that?
So what's going to happen?
The red peak is going to split.
There's going to be a lower
and a higher red peak.
in a higher blue peak.
So it's going to look like that, right?
And those that's going to be Jay,
if these shifts are Jay over for this
transition got longer by Jay over to this
one, got shorter by Jay over to, so
the difference between them as Jay now.
So that's where these,
in terms of the energy of the
things interacting with one another,
that's where we get chemical
shift difference and spins.
Been coupling Jay. Okay?
So that looks just fine.
And that's what's called
the first order spectrum.
That's what we've been talking about.
But there are higher order effects
and I think you'll find this cute.
Okay.
Because Jay does something else
besides just shifting these levels,
right?
It also mixes this state with this state,
okay? And it mixes them
into a sum and a difference.
And of course we've seen
things just like this before.
That's what it looks like
in the case of magnetism.
The sum has the two pointing
in opposite directions along Z,
but not along x. And the, and the, uh,
the difference has them pointing
opposite directions all together. Okay?
Now when you do that,
when you mix this with this,
you get the difference,
which turns out to be a little
lower in energy and the sun,
which is a little higher in energy.
And of course that's just like mixing a
p orbital on carbon with a p orbital on
oxygen and a CEO double bond. You mixed
the two, their energies don't match.
So you get this one has more of that in
it. This one has more of that and it,
oops, I wrote this wrong and that should
be red and blue. Okay, I'll change that.
Everybody with me.
So I didn't tell you exactly why these,
why it couples to this, but it does. Okay,
so this shifts those energies,
right?
So that,
notice that that makes the
reds a little bit smaller.
Both of the reds smaller,
right?
And both of the blues larger,
So it shifted the reds to the right
and the blues to the left, right?
So the peaks aren't so Delta isn't exactly
what you thought it was going to be.
Right.
That is the shift.
The difference between the average of
those two isn't exactly the chemical shift
because of this higher order effect.
But there's something much more
interesting that happens, right?
That one is non magnetic.
Obviously they cancel one another,
but how about the other one?
It's not magnetic along Z,
right?
But it's just as magnetic along x
as either of those other states.
The top one of the bottom one is right,
so it has this resultant,
so it says magnetic perpendicular to the
main field as either the one that was
where they're both against the field
of the one where they're both with the
field. So this one is magnetic
and that one's not magnetic.
That is, this one can interact
with the magnetic field of light.
But this one can't interact with
the magnetic field of light.
So if we look over here,
we see that this one is weakened.
It's not interacting with light.
This one is interacting even
more strongly with light.
Hey,
now what that means is, so this one
is really strong in this one is weak.
Now in terms of interaction with light,
okay?
So this influences the intensity
of the transitions. Okay?
Now what it does is it makes the
ones that involve this level,
that's this red one in this blue one
gets stronger and these get weaker like
that.
Hey,
so what's going to happen over here?
This one, which is the shortest of all,
and this one, which is the longest of
all, this one in this one get weak,
or pardon me? Pardon me? Uh,
no. This is the longest of all.
This is the shortest of all this red one.
So those get weak,
but the inner ones get strong.
So it changes to look like that.
And the more you mix them,
the bigger they're separated by Delta
or Delta over to their mixed by Jay.
So the more the bigger Jay is compared
to Delta, the more they'll mix,
the more they'll be exactly like this,
which is when they're completely mixed in,
the stronger these will become in the
week or these will become so is the delta
gets smaller and smaller in terms of
Hertz. As you change the magnetic field,
the outer peaks shrink. And
the inner peaks grow, right?
So that's why methane has a single
peak and you can't see it splitting,
even though the coupling is still there,
you just can't see it.
So the radio frequency light loses its
handle on the flanking peaks as Delta
becomes small compared to
Jay as shown here, right?
So by increasing Delta measured in Hertz,
that is by using an expensive big field,
you make things more like first order
spectra that are easy to interpret.
One to two, one to two to one, one,
three, three, one, one, four, six, four,
one and so on. Okay? So that's,
that's the subtle aspect.
Now we're going to talk about how you
use Nmr to study dynamics to study rates
and what we mean by the Nmr time
scale and how decoupling works.
Okay?
So we looked at this spectrum last time.
This is a spectrum of ethanol measure.
Does it says over here by your
own ta? Uh, they'll Lichter.
Okay. Now, if we look at these
three peaks with that we see there,
the Oah,
the ch two and the ch three and we analyze
these last time and saw that this is
a triplet. This is a triplet
both being split by this ch two,
but this one is a quartet of doublets.
Okay,
now that was measured in
dms. Oh, solvent, right?
For a special reason.
Remember that peak came from dms,
so that had a little hydrogen in
it as well as deuterium. Okay?
If we measured in chloroform was a little
bit of acid in there or a Phil did,
he measured this one as well. Notice
the peaks shift a little bit, right?
Especially the Oah peak shifts a lot,
right? The other shift a little bit,
this one, not too much. Okay.
But what's much more interested in than
these shifts is what the peaks actually
looked like in terms of their splitting.
Now bear in mind, this ohp cause here,
it's now over here, but I'm drawing
it here. So instead of a triplet,
it's now a singlet, right? And this one,
instead of being a quartet of
doublets is just a quartet.
No changes over here,
right?
So what's,
we've lost the splitting
between the age and the ch two.
It's no longer split.
It's not split by the ch two and
the ch two is not split by the age.
So what's going on when we
did this? In fact, let's all,
let's what happens if we
don't have the acid in there?
If we don't have the acid in there,
this peak moves way over here.
This one stays the same place.
We're still in chloroform solvent,
and this one stays the same place,
but the Oah really changes.
Okay, but look, but what's again,
much more interesting is what the patterns
look like. They look like that now,
right?
So this, instead of being
either a triplet or a single,
it is a really broad low peak,
right?
This one is, it still looks a little
bit like a quartet of Douglas,
but it's much broadened, right? This
one is the same as it was before,
right?
So something really funny is happening
here. Now let's look at the integral ills,
right? Okay. So within experimental error,
the it's one to two to three,
right?
It's 0.96 to two to 3.04 in uh,
in dms. So, okay,
in a CDCL three it's 1.0 to 2.0 to
3.05 again with an experimental error.
One, two, three.
But the one that had a little bit of acid
in it is much more interesting, right?
It's two to three. That's
fine. But this is bigger.
1.1400000000000001.
So that peak,
this peak here,
the sharp peak here in the one
that has acid in it, right,
is bigger.
They're more protons there than just one.
How did that happen?
It's an average of both the Oah that's
on the alcohol and the h plus right now.
Let's see, how did that happen? Well,
h plus can go onto the alcohol and then
the age that was on the alcohol can come
back into the solution.
So we've exchanged those two H's and if
that happens rapidly there h is moving
all over.
Most of the time they're on alcohol,
but sometime 14% there
on h there is h plus.
And what you're seeing is the
average of those in this case.
So this is averaging the H's
are zipping around from Mali,
not only from,
uh,
not only between acid and alcohol,
but from one alcohol,
two another alcohol,
right? By way of the acid.
And what that means is,
remember the reason we see splitting
is that there are these spin isomers.
There are different molecules in there.
Some molecules have the neighboring ch
two both up, some have them both down,
some have one up and one down.
But if you're zipping from
molecule to molecule very rapidly,
you see the average,
which is nothing, right?
So when we have acid in there and it's
averaging very fast by going on and off
and then going to different molecules,
right? Then we see sharp peak here,
the splitting disappears
here. What's going on? Okay,
well how about the Roi h
chemical shift, that thing? Okay.
It's the average of many
hydrogen bonded structures.
So because they're, the hydrogen bonds
keep getting made and broken very rapidly.
So you average among many
different hydrogen bonds,
but the age stays with
the original molecule.
It's not going from molecule to molecule
and just breaking hydrogen bonds and
going back and forth and that and how
fast you do that and how much you do.
It depends on concentration on what the
solvent is on the temperature and so on.
But how about the spin spin splitting
between the ch two in the, Ooh, right?
That can be the average involving
h exchange among many molecules.
It's fast if you have h plus,
it's slow in dms. So, so in dms,
so you saw h is staying
with their molecule and you
see they're splitting in h
plus they go from molecule to
molecule fast. You see the average.
And what happens if you don't,
if you have chloroform,
but you don't have the h plus,
it's some kind of averaging is beginning
to happen it looks like. So let's,
so it's clear that if you have h
plus in there, it can zip around.
What happens if you're just making
and breaking hydrogen bonds? Well,
you could have three, uh, uh,
alcohol's hydrogen bonded together in
a circle k and they could trade which
hydrogen.
So this is a mechanism for exchanging
hydrogens from one alcohol to another.
And then as you go,
as the tremor comes apart,
the molecules become another tremor
and do this exchange another, another,
another. This is a
mechanism, a slow mechanism,
much slower than this h plus thing,
right?
Which can allow slow averaging of the H's,
But if you have dms, l was the
solvent. This doesn't happen. Why?
Because dms, oh, falls forms very
strong hydrogen bonds with Doh,
and it doesn't form these trimers in
which the hydrogens can shift from one
molecule to the other, right? If, if
DMS, so we're a strong enough base,
it could pull the h off and
be like an acid catalysts.
That would be a base catalyst. Pull it
off one molecule, put it on another one,
right?
But it's not that strong base.
It's just strong enough to forbid
forming those hydrogen bonded trimers.
Okay, so we can get this
averaging, but wait a second.
We looked at this one a couple of lectures
ago when we were looking at IIR and
we said that even though this
was said to be an anhydrate,
it had these water peaks and we said
there were two kinds of water peaks.
They're the ones that are hydrogen
bonded here and the ones that are not
hydrogen bonded. That's
two different peaks, right?
But shouldn't those average the
same way they do it in Nmr, right?
Where whereas you make one as Molly,
you go from molecule to Mali is
molecules come apart and come together.
Hydrogen bonding,
you quickly average those.
Why don't you get averaging in the IRR
when you do get averaging in the Nmr?
Another question is what's fast?
How fast does it have to be to see a
blur or to see the average as a sharp
average rather than to see the
two distinct things? Okay? Now,
uh, this particular sample is a solid,
so you could imagine that these,
that these are held in place by
the surrounding molecules, right?
But you see the same effect in solutions.
So that's not the difference. Okay.
Now notice that in are we have wave
numbers here that tell us how fast this is
vibrating and how fast this is vibrating.
And this one is a 110 times 10
to the 10th hurts. And this one,
this Ooh bond is 102 times
10 to the 10th hurts.
That is the difference between them
is 10 to the 11th hurts. Right?
Whereas the difference we were looking
at in the alcohol things were a hundred
hertz or a few hundred hertz at most.
Okay.
So this is a much bigger frequency
difference here in IRR than it was an Nmr.
Now what does that have
to do with anything?
How long does it take to
measure a frequency? Precisely
how long is long for
purposes of an average? Okay,
well suppose you have two
different swings. I'm going
to put these two guys on,
swings up to the ceiling and they'll
start swinging and they swing at a certain
rate, right? But they won't swing
it exactly the same rate. Okay.
If this, if this, if the, uh, if they're
a little bit different, the two swings.
Okay. So suppose one of them
is pretty fast swinging.
One of them swings at 20 hertz and
the other swings swings at 21 hertz.
Right. And I'm going to try to
push them, but I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna adjust the
frequency I'm pushing out.
I'm just going to sit here
and go bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom, Bom, Bom, bom, Bom, bom.
And I'm going to do it at 20 hertz.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
So the guy that's swinging
naturally at 20 hertz,
I always push him every time
he comes just right. Okay.
So the light field in the,
in the I our case or the Nmr case,
uh,
matches perfectly for 20 hertz,
but it doesn't match for 21 hurts.
Of course.
Now if I just did it for a little while
on the 21 hurts just for a little while,
it would be all most in phase
and I'd be pushing them. Right?
But after a little while,
we get out of phase and I'm pushing when
he's coming in and pulling when he's
going and so on. So it's gonna,
it's gonna get out of whack. Now,
how long does it take to get out of whack?
Right?
How long do I have to be doing this in
order to find out that I'm not really
doing anything with it? Well,
notice that a one pulse,
a one second pulse samples,
the full range of phases
from being completely in
phase to coming back to being
completely in phase again. So if I
do it for one second, I get nothing,
okay? It just cancels on this
one. Everything was golden,
okay.
But obviously then there's
no net interaction with the
light in that one over a
course of one second.
So a one second light pulse can clearly
distinguish between 20 hertz and 21
hurts everybody with me.
That means suppose we have 22 hertz.
Okay. A swing that I'm trying with my
light to hit, but I'm going at 20 hertz,
right? So that goes through two
complete cycles there. In fact,
it goes through one complete cycle.
You can tell it's not
working after only half, uh,
after only half a second.
Um,
that is one over the difference in lambda
that's long enough to sample the full
range,
favorable and unfavorable.
So I can more quickly tell the
difference when the frequencies are more
different. Right. It depends on
one over the frequency difference.
That's how long I have to go to know that
I'm not gonna get any action out of it.
Okay. Now, here's the interesting thing.
Suppose the frequency is changing in time.
It's averaging a proton is jumping from
one position to another and changing its
frequency.
Okay?
Suppose that it goes for
20 at 22 hertz for awhile.
Then at 20 hertz for awhile it's in a
different environment than at 22 hertz.
Then at 20 Hertz,
then at 22 hertz,
then at 20 hertz for awhile.
Okay.
Jumping back and forth randomly
at a certain rate. Okay.
Now obviously that's not going
to work with the 22 hertz light.
It goes in and out of phase,
right?
So we won't get any absorption of 22
hertz light supposedly tried 20 hertz
light. So we'll move it up there.
Again, it goes in and out of phase,
right? No Pr, no profit in that one.
But suppose I tried 21 hurts
right now.
It stays pretty much in phase,
so it's averaging properly.
Right.
And so what will you will see is we
have a very good match at 21 hurts the
average frequency and we'll
see a single sharp peak. Uh,
21 hertz will work 20 hertz won't.
22 we'll, we'll see an average peak.
What's the,
what's determining it's how long the
pulse is compared to the difference in
frequency. If the pulse is
long enough, uh, that, uh,
as long as the difference in
frequency, then we can tell it. Okay.
So when do peaks average?
When Adam's don't stay put long enough
to tell the difference in frequency
between the two sites that
they're changing between.
So if two peaks differ by a hundred Hertz,
you have to count for a hundredth of
a second roughly to tell them apart.
Okay.
But in the eye,
are they differed by 10 to the 11th hurts?
Right.
So the exchange of position would have
to be 10 to the 11th times a second.
Right. In order to be able to see
separate peaks, right? And, and that's,
that's as fast as Adam's vibrate. They
can't change their partners that rapidly.
Right?
So that's why in the IRR you don't see
averaging when you do see it in the Nmr,
because the Nmr differences
in frequency are small.
Just a few hurts or a few
hundreds of hurts, right?
So if something happens in 100th of a
second, you can see separate peaks for it.
Okay.
But you can't do that in the IRR because
the differences in frequency are so
large.
Okay.
So this gives rise then to
what's called the Nmr timescale.
Now suppose you had Cyclohexane
d 11 it gives this spectrum,
right?
It gives spectrum for axial
and equatorial hydrogens,
right?
Incidentally,
notice that that's sort of as if this
were like benzine with a ring current,
it gets shifted down when it's out beside
and shift it up when it's along the
axis.
At least that's a way to remember it.
I'm not really sure that
that's the explanation.
I'm not really sure that that a
ring current is true. But anyhow,
you can remember which is
which if you want to, okay,
now notice this is a
special Molecule d 11 why?
Just one proton? And the reason is
that you get very complicated spins,
spins,
splitting.
If these are all hydrogen because
the axial will be split by that.
This equatorial will be split by that
axial one because they don't have the same
chemical shift,
right?
So they're going to split one another
and then they'll all be also be split by
these with different
coupling constants and so on.
So we make all those deteriorate, we get
sharper peaks so we can study it. Okay,
so it's d 11 right?
But notice this is at minus
89 degrees centigrade.
And watch what happens if
you start warming up that
the difference between the,
the difference in a chemical
shift is 0.48 parts per million.
And this was measured in
an old spectrometer in,
in 1964 by frank bovie at bell labs.
And at the difference here is,
is 0.48 parts per million at
60 megahertz or it's 29 hertz.
We got to put it in frequency. If we
want to talk about this kind of thing.
So 29 hertz difference in frequency.
Okay,
now we go from minus 89 to minus 68.
The peaks get broad to
minus 63 broader still.
And moving in at 60,
they coalesce and become a single
peak at minus 60. At minus 57,
it starts sharpening up and sharpened up.
Still more at minus 49.
And what do you think that looks
like at room temperature? So single,
really sharp peak,
sharp as these are sharper.
So it's detangle sharp peak up there.
Uh, even if you have c six h 12,
because it's flipping back and forth
rapidly enough that it's averaging the
chemical shifts and once the chemical
shifts become the same on average,
then you can't see the
splitting anymore. Okay? So,
so cyclohexane gives a single sharp peak,
but this allows you to tell
how fast, because you know
this frequency difference,
right?
So it turns out that they less to
give a single peak when it's about,
uh, at about that same, uh, the lifetime
is about the same as that. It's,
it's,
it's actually four times that.
But for qualitative purposes it's the
same at the time they coalesce. So,
so it's about, it's about a hundred
times a second, right? That it,
that it's flipping back and forth at minus
60 degrees. But you can measure this,
you can fit these lines to theoretical
calculations for rates at other
temperatures.
Or you can go to a different spectrometer
which has the same chemical shift
difference,
but a bigger frequency difference.
And then get at what temperature you
have that frequency or four times that
frequency, right? So that's a
great way to measure the rates.
And by measuring the rates
at different temperatures,
you can get what the barrier is.
And that's where we got the number from
last semester when we were talking about
confirmational analysis,
we said that the barrier for flipping one
chair to another in Cyclo hexane is 10
and a half kilocalories per mole.
And that's where you get it.
It's not easy to measure
something like that,
but Nmr allows you to do it right.
So this is a handy way to measure really
fast rates and very small barriers that
correspond to these fast rates.
So the Nmr application and dynamics is
very important for studying a fast rate
processes. Now let me see. I
at the time, yeah, we got, uh,
let me just go very quickly. I'm going
to go really quickly through this, so to,
so we can get to a little
bit of something else.
But this was the kind of question
that I might ask on an exam. Uh,
the first part of the question one
had to do with making this molecule.
We've talked about making
Hemi asset towels before,
but the relevant part here is
question two, which was the sketch,
what you'd expect for the Nmr
spectrum of that compound. Okay.
So let's look at the different,
uh,
groups and you predict what we're going
to get in terms of chemical shift.
First A, how about its chemical shift?
Where do you expect that on the spectrum?
The OAH, it'll be downfield
because of the, oh,
but it'll be almost any place because
of the hydrogen bonding and so on.
That has a big range.
And how about the splitting?
Yeah.
Should it be a singlet doublet,
a triplet court that quintet?
One four, six, four one.
What determines the splitting of this?
Jeez.
How many protons are on the
next adjacent Adam? Right?
So here we coupled through this
bond, this bond, uh, to here,
right? These are too far away.
Those are removed by one, two,
three, four bonds. But to
hear it's only one, two,
three bonds. Right? So it
should be a doublet, right?
Everybody agree?
It should be a doublet.
Sebastian,
you shake your head slightly is on,
it depends in dms. So it would be a
doublet, but mostly you don't use that.
And in chloroform it would be exchanging,
right?
So you wouldn't see the splitting.
Okay.
So it could be almost any place between
one and six for hydrogen bonding and the
splitting is probably,
it would be a broad singlet because
of rapid ohia exchange. Okay.
Now let's go to be, where
should that be? Kind of cool.
We'll ship way up the
right way. Up The left,
in the middle,
almost to the right.
Okay, so it's c h three
is that are on, it's a co,
it's hydrogens that are on the carbon
and the next atom is carbon too.
That's up at the right. Right. But it
has a couple of oxygens here. Right.
So it'll be shifted down a little bit.
Okay.
Slightly de shielded by two
atoms on the neighboring carbon.
So one might predict someplace between
one and two and there's a compound that's
very like that. That isn't 1.3
okay. How about the splitting?
Okay.
By this one, now it has three bonds
to get from here to here. Right?
So that should be a splitting.
There's no exchanging there. Okay.
So it should be a one to one doublet
split by Jay should be about seven hertz.
Okay. Now how about c?
What should it look like?
Where should, what should its chemical
shift be relative to say these hydrogens?
Eric was saying, I said double it.
Quadruple. I knocked the splitting.
Where's should watch it?
The chemical shift. B first.
Okay.
It's attached to a carbon.
What's that carbon attached to Amy.
Their oxygen. So will be shifted
down more than this one was right,
because it's closer to
the oxygen's. Right. So,
so it's de shielded by two oxygen
atoms on the same carbon. Right. So,
uh, it'd be between four
and a half. There's a real,
there's a analog that's at
4.7. Okay. Now how about Derek,
now you tell us about the
splitting of this one.
I think it's a doubling or
tripling or quadrupling downwards.
I don't know that it would be if it were
split by this, that makes it a quartet.
Alright. Yeah. And this
would make it a doublet,
except we already said that
that's probably exchanging,
it would depend on the solvent,
right?
So probably it would just be a one to
three to three to one quartet, right.
Ajay about sonar. It's okay. Let's
keep going. How about this one?
What's that going to be like,
Jack?
Chemical shift for that ch three,
pardon me?
Maybe about two because it's attached
to a carbon which bears oxygen,
right? So, so slightly de shielded by
the assets rather like this one. Right.
Which is attached to a carbon which
bore two oxygens. So not as far down.
Is that okay? The 1.1. Okay. And
how about the splitting of that one,
Jack?
Just the Dublin because these are
too far away. Okay. One, two, one,
double at seven hertz. Okay. Now let's
go to e. What's it gonna look like
about its chemical shift?
Debbie,
be,
yeah, because it's got an oxygen on
the same carbon, right? Right. So it's,
it's 3.8 out that,
okay.
And how about its multiplicity?
How many hydrogens? Splitting it,
three Vons away.
I can't hear.
Well, we already that this one is
going to be a doublet split by that.
If that's true, if, if this one
splits these than these, split that.
And so does the top ones.
So how many altogether?
Six. So it'll be seven lines
in the binomial intensity,
right? Seven line, multiply from the
six atoms on the neighboring carbons.
Seven Hertz. Right. So that's going to be
really, you know, the whole bunch of them.
Seven lines. Okay. Now how about F,
Chris? Same as D, right? It's
got the same conductivity as d,
same hydrogen coupling and so on,
but it's slightly de shielded by the
Austrian out on that. So that's this.
I copied that from here and I copied
this from here. And that's what you said,
but it's different from d
because here is a chiral center.
So one of those is our pro our and
the other is pro s, right? They,
they're different within other
chiral center. So in fact,
when you look at a situation like that,
there are two that are really close
to one another, two doublets. Okay.
There they're about the same.
But I, I, I caught you. What?
All right. Yeah, you do see
that not in every molecule.
Notice that's an ice appropriate group
to ch three s on a Cah attached to
something. If the rest of the molecule
is chiral, those will be different.
Right? That depends on what the
molecule is. Sometimes hardly,
hardly observable,
but very often you can see it.
I saw one when I was a graduate student,
I got a spectrum like that and I couldn't,
I said, what the heck is going on?
So that was a standard question I would
ask on exams down here of graduate
students at that time after I
learned it myself. Okay, now,
proton decoupling.
Um,
let me just start this and then
we'll show the example next time.
So we have JC 13 h here.
Okay,
now notice that when we put this in a
magnetic field, a certain magnetic field,
the Proton, we'll precess at 100
megahertz. How about the c 13? Well,
it precess it a hundred megahertz.
No, because it's a much weaker magnet.
It doesn't feel as much torque.
It doesn't precess as fast, right?
So the h has a steady
field in that direction,
or there are other ones that have exactly
the same steady field in the opposite
direction. Now see, see,
13 is 25 megahertz.
It's only a quarter as strong as a magnet.
So it precesses much more slowly.
It's a smaller magnet and
it can be either up or down.
Okay? So both of these things
are happening when we put
it in a magnetic field.
Okay? And here's the Nmr spectrum. And
we've seen that and saw the, the uh,
the satellites that the,
these come that peak,
this peak comes from.
See twelves,
this is from [inaudible]
when they're down.
And this is the Proton precession when
the c 13 is up reinforcing the applied
field, okay? And at the same time,
if we looked at the c 13 spectrum,
notice that essentially all of of
hydrogen is protium only 0.015%,
very little as deuterium.
So you don't see that big peak in the
middle here because all the hydrogen is
either this way or this
way, right? And the amount,
the magnitude of this splitting in
both cases, 125 hertz, that's fine.
Okay, so now suppose we
do something really cute.
Suppose we've put two
radio frequencies in, okay,
one one at 100 megahertz,
one at 25 megahertz, right?
But what we're going to do it,
the way we're going to do it is to have
irradiate 100 megahertz all the time.
So what does that,
but just do a pulse,
a 90 degree pulse of the c 13 to twist
it down into the plane and then allow it
to precess and that's what we're going
to listen to, to see if we got a signal.
We're going to listen to the c
13 while irradiating the age.
Now what effect does that happen?
If you were in a frame
rotating a hundred megahertz,
you'd see that this little hundred
megahertz field is going to cause this,
this the hydrogens to precess
like this to go up, down,
up, down, up, down. What determines
how fast they go up and down,
how fast they've precess.
What determines that?
It's how big this field is,
how strong the field is.
The stronger the field, the
faster the precession. Okay,
so that means h is going
to be up then down,
then up then down and how fast it's
going up, down, up, down, up, down.
Depends on how much power
we put into our radio. Okay?
If we do it fast enough,
we see the average of the [inaudible]
and decouple the spectrum.
We can see the c 13 spectrum without
the h splitting it by making the H's
quickly go up and down.
How fast do they have to go up and down
in order to average the 125
hertz splitting to be nothing,
to just be a single Pete,
how fast.
Yeah.
Once you've had time
to review the lecture,
you'll be able to answer that
about 125 times a second,
right? The frequency differences, how
fast you have to flip to average. Right?
So if you put enough
power on the hydrogen,
you remove the splitting
from the c 13 specter,
which can be handy as we'll
show you the next time.
Okay.
So the decoupling power determines the
rate of this precession and this we'll
see next time.